ثبت أن الرئيس وجه
أو نسق مع كوهين لارتكاب
هذه الجنايات إذا تم إثبات ذلك وأنا
أفهم أنه لم يتم
ادعاء ذلك من قبل المدعين ، لكن
لم يتم إثبات ذلك إذا ثبت أنه من
الجيد أن تلك الجرائم التي
يمكن عزلها  أن تكون جرائم
قابلة للمساءلة سواء كانت مهمة بما يكفي لتبرير
المساءلة مسألة مختلفة
ولكن بالتأكيد ستكون جرائم تستوجب العزل
لأنه على الرغم من أنها ارتكبت
قبل أن يصبح الرئيس رئيسًا ،
إلا أنها ارتكبت في
خدمة الحصول على
المنصب بطريقة احتيالية  سيكون ذلك
بمثابة جريمة تستوجب العزل ، لكن
حقيقة الأمر هي أن ما نراه من
لوائح الاتهام وبيانات الاتهام هذه
هو مؤامرة أوسع بكثير
ضد الشعب الأمريكي تنطوي على
هذه المدفوعات التي تنطوي على
محاولة للتأثير على الحملة
بشكل غير لائق  مع مدفوعات غير لائقة
يشارك فيها الروس الذين يحاولون
التأثير في الحملة i  نتحدث عن
الرئيس وهو يكذب لمدة عام كامل
بشأن الترتيبات التجارية المستمرة الخاصة به
والمعاملات التجارية مع الروس
التي تنطوي على إعاقة سير العدالة ، كل
هذه الأمور يجب أن ينظر إليها بجدية شديدة من
قبل الكونجرس من قبل المستشار الخاص
ووزارة العدل
ومعرفة ما هي الإجراءات  يجب علينا
بعد ذلك أن نأخذ ، والواضح أيضًا هو
أن الكونجرس الجمهوري حاول
تمامًا حماية الرئيس ،
ولن يحاول الكونجرس الجديد حماية الرئيس ، ولكنه
سيحاول الوصول إلى حقيقة الأمر من
أجل خدمة الشعب الأمريكي.